PayPal collected a whole bunch of people  who were young and intense and we're  entrepreneurial themselves and then all  of a sudden it was bought by eBay so  once you these folks are like okay well  what do I do next  and so you know Chad and Steve go into  YouTube and Elon goes and does Tesla and  SpaceX and Jeremy and rusty Yelp and you  know I do LinkedIn and and and and yet  because we've had this intense  experience together we all have still  really tight network and so we're all  calling each other going hey I'm think  about doing this what do you think  clearly call for what so for example  macro economic financial bold models  I'll call Peter the intersection of kind  of interesting business models or  business technologies things like Big  Data Max Levchin for a willingness to  just think super big with risk is not a  variable Elon